the red carpet is rolling out over at
virgin hotel it is the old hard rock
hotel
but it has a new name and a new face
alex and they are giving us a sneak peek
before doors officially open this
thursday
hector mejia live with our first look
inside good morning hector looks
beautiful
hey there guys good morning it's
absolutely beautiful we're going to ring
the doorbell here
did you hear that we're going to go
inside and give you a sneak peek
you know actually a third of the rooms
here are suites this is one of them and
joining us live we have boz bosworth
here to talk to us not just about this
room but about the
1500 rooms that are opening on thursday
on thursday good morning hector so good
to see you welcome
actually we are in a junior suite right
now uh in the
in the canyon tower which is the
original one the
original tower was known as the casino
tower and this is actually an original
room of the hard rock from 1995.
so about the same layout about the same
layout it's uh this particular room this
particular junior suite is 900 square
feet
wow and so we have some of the same
elements that we see down below
on the lobby floor that's correct yeah i
think one of the things you'll notice is
the consistency of the design
uh hector throughout the entire property
you'll see the elements of the journey
through the desert and our desert modern
motif
brought through every aspect of the
property including our uniforms
for our team members the uniforms too
yes everything was designed
consistently you know in the last hour
we didn't have a lot of time to talk
about what's next in terms of
what's next to open here on the property
what are some of those areas
uh after this thursday uh what we'll be
following next will be cassie beach
house will be opening up on april 9th
followed by todd owl's restaurant
everybody's very excited about that
um after his ice cream uh which who
doesn't love ice cream right who doesn't
love ice cream particularly after his
ice cream
and then our backyard our resort pool
will open uh which is
such a unique uh unique pool environment
for las vegas
followed by ilya which is our mykonos
desi um inspired day club which will
open up in may and it's pool season so a
lot of people looking forward to the
opening that's correct in time for pool
season of course
with awful culvert safeties and uh and
adherence to regulations with public
gatherings
on that note we were also chatting about
the technology right now during the age
of covid can you tell us a little bit
about the technology you guys are using
you know because we were on the
sidelines here during the pandemic we
had a chance
to really watch uh all the different
best practices in las vegas
and all the best practices of our our
all-star group of operators whether it
be virgin hilton mohegan aeg
are lined up restaurants will all bring
fantastic you know
and carefully designed coveted safety
practices to bear here
technology changed and every week was
like another year
in learning more about technology for
the pandemic so we've been able to bring
the best of that technology to the
property whether it be through
improvements in our filtration system or
even the nanotechnology as it relates to
uh spread spraying clean that can kill
microbes for up to a month
all right boz thank you so much for
having us we'll be talking a lot more
uh throughout the rest of the hour we'll
be back in about half an hour with
another live interview for now
reporting live hector mejia and boz
thank you
back to you guys great thank you oh
they've done such a good job hector and
it's been a
long time so it's good to see yeah 400
days or so more than a year so nice to
see the new
the old hard rock is the new version
good stuff hector will catch up with you
and boz in a few moments